foreign
[Music]
objection I've often encountered over my
years as a talking head and this is
something that everyone in media hears
ad nauseum is that um you know I spend
too much time focused on the negative
why don't you ever talk about positive
things the objector asks why not spend
time discussing encouraging and
wholesome topics that's what I really
want to hear about
now the truth is that I do sometimes
talk about positive things I do in fact
spend time on my show and on other
platforms discussing more light-hearted
and happier topics on occasion at least
light-hearted and happy to me
but the people who demand such content
are nowhere to be seen once it's
provided okay they don't say hey thanks
for this it's just what I asked for
instead they say nothing because the
truth is that they've probably changed
the channel they've closed out the video
because the further truth is that they
don't really want these more wholesome
themes they say they do but when they
get it they're bored
that's part of the reason why you don't
see more of the sort of cheerful and
uplifting content that so many people
pretend to want but rarely support
whenever they get it but the other
potential reason for a lack of such
content
is that
when someone in the public light shares
an encouraging thought or a happy moment
with the public
it is nearly certain that he will be
ripped to shreds by a million crazed
vultures who seek to devour happiness
like scavengers on Roadkill
uh now the point here isn't just to
whine and say what was me there's a
there's a larger point I want to make
but case in point
consider the happy moment that I
experienced and shared with the world
and have talked a little bit about on
the show late last week the day after
our Twins were born I announced the news
on Twitter and since I'm a dad of six
now I I you know I can't help but
include an extremely lame dad joke in
moments like this it's a compulsion and
also you might say a solemn
responsibility to ruin a profound moment
with a corny joke this is just it's what
we're supposed to do so I tweeted uh
kids number five and six were born last
night the males and the family now
outnumber the females five to three my
master plan is complete mom and babies
are healthy and doing well thank you for
all your prayers
that's why I said that's all I said
the totally hilarious joke about the
boys outnumbering the girls and a bit
about how I somehow planned this from
the start is a version of a joke that
approximately I don't know 700 000
people have said to me whenever they
find out that we're having two more boys
in fact it's the sort of Battle of the
Sexes type joke that families with boys
and girls make all the time amongst each
other it's all very normal
but as we've seen there is nothing that
the internet hates more than normal
which is why this tweet announcing the
birth of my children attracted hundreds
of outraged responses people outraged
so to be clear these are people who are
actively mad about a stranger announcing
the birth of his children
that emotion okay outrage over a birth
announcement is it's an emotion that
that a healthy human being has likely
never felt it's it's an emotion not even
available to a healthy person they
wouldn't know how to generate that
emotion if they wanted to
and yet many people who are
apparently capable of experiencing such
an emotion or who wish to pretend that
they experience it made their voices
heard and I'm not going to go through
and read them all
um just suffice it to say again hundreds
of people
comments sending me messages very upset
um wanting to taking time by the way
it's like I just had kids it's like to
me so here it's text mine to lecture me
about you know the manner in which I
announce it
because I have time to really think
about that
just one tweet selected at random is a
fairly representative of the whole so
this was the General tenor um a woman
responded imagine your twins being born
and you tweet that your master plan of
having more boys than girls in a family
is finally complete as the oldest of
five girls I am completely effing sick
of men celebrating male babies as
inherently more valuable very sorry for
this man's daughters
I think it's also worth singling out
this other response one other from a
woman who pretends to be a reverend uh
Reverend Kim Chaffey tweeted and
Reverend in quotes reverend in you know
Big Air quotes are Kim Chaffey tweeted
it might be humorous where not for his
patriarchal history and attitude towards
women not appropriate not funny
by the way um
this is a woman named Kim
who responds to a joke like that by
saying not appropriate or funny you
already have in your mind an image of
what this person looks like and it's
exactly that you're exactly right it's
that it's that person
and there are plenty more where these
came from this is to say nothing of the
people who took the time to publicly
wish that my children turn out gay or
trans that was another big response it's
quite interesting actually that those
who pretend to support gay and trans
people are also the ones most likely to
accuse you of being gay or trans as an
insult or to wish it on your children as
a curse
now over the following week I posted a
few more times about the birth each time
I was rebuked for one reason or another
and always there followed many ill
wishes to me and my family and my
newborn Sons most of this came from the
left but not all of it for instance in
response to a picture
of me simply
um sitting and holding the babies
is it uh and I don't usually post
pictures of my kids online but they're
infants and you can barely see them so
you know it's it's fine but a YouTuber
uh from the Mana sphere named Ryan Stone
tweeted
showing off the F trophies for clout
that trophies like the f word trophies
that's what I was so the babies are
trophies that I'm showing off
he then went on a multi-tweet tirade
complaining about men who take pictures
with their own children
it's not manly apparently
to love your kids is not and be proud of
them it's not mainly this is perhaps not
a surprise that a picture of a proud
father would be so upsetting to the sort
of man who clearly never had one
now all of this reached its tapiothus uh
uh a few days ago
when I answered a question about whether
I'd be taking a long paternity leave and
I said in reply and here I directly
quote myself
I said
um nope I'll be back to work in a couple
of days
that's what I said that was it I'll be
back to work in a couple of days end of
statement and yet even that was
offensive to some people and not a small
number so here we can use this response
as representative one man said Matt my
man I'm happy for you for real
congratulations twins a lot of work a
lot of fun good luck you do know I hope
that you could just be gracious and not
dog whistle malign people who take
paternity leave
yes to say when you're returning to work
is to dog whistle malign men on
paternity leave you can't even say when
you're coming back to work without
offending people who are not coming back
to work yet
this is ludicrous for many reasons
beginning with the fact that I don't
need a dog whistle to malign anyone if I
want to do it I'll do it openly I think
I've proved that if nothing else during
my career
now you might listen to all this and say
okay sure of course this was the
response you got it's the Internet it's
not real life that's just how people are
on the Internet besides the vast
majority of people were encouraging and
positive and congratulatory and these
trolls are in the minority and on that
latter point I agree most people have
been very supportive sending their well
wishes and prayers and for that as I
said I'm profoundly grateful
as to the former I certainly do not
agree now if many people are vicious and
vile and insane on the internet then
they are by definition vicious and vile
and insane in real life because the
Internet is real life it exists in
reality it is used by people in reality
so if you say something to somebody on
the internet you have said it to them in
real life
this idea that it's that it is it's some
sort of dream or alternate Dimension it
doesn't count
is it doesn't make sense it is a
communication device
saying the Internet isn't real life it's
like writing an insult on a piece of
paper and then handing it to someone and
then and then telling them they have no
right to be upset about it because you
didn't insult them in real life you only
insulted them on the piece of paper
relax man it's just a piece of paper
now it's certainly true that many of the
trolls who say heinous things on the
internet would never do it face to face
nobody would come up to me in person and
say for example I hope your newborn
children end up being trans
nobody would do that
um I'm out in public all the time and
nobody comes up to me it says anything
like that to my face
many have said it to me on the internet
never would say to my face
um that however doesn't make the
statement any less real and it also
doesn't make it any better because it
just it just makes them cowards on top
of being perverts and degenerates and
psychos
but let me guess my real point and the
real point isn't simply to just complain
about people being mean and weird on the
internet instead you know this has been
I think yet another opportunity
to learn a very valuable lesson about
the modern world
which is this that that many people hate
happiness
and this is really what lies at the root
of The Psychotic backlash that I
received for committing the sin of
talking about my children in public
I'm a family man and I'm happy in that
role and I'm proud of my family that's
why I talk about it
and that makes certain people very upset
why why do people get offended by the
why get offended by happiness
because they're deeply unhappy and
miserable themselves and they take your
happiness as a personal affront you know
the adage about Misery loving company is
true but I think it's important to
understand why it's true
that this sort of miserable selfish
person has given up on striving for
anything better in life instead they try
to attain Happiness by using this kind
of bell curve method if they can drag
everyone else down if they can spread
their misery around then they'll have
increased their own happiness in
comparison to the average
it's like if you earn more money you'll
have made yourself richer but if you
earn the same amount while everyone else
loses money you'll have closed the gap
between yourself and the richest person
thereby making yourself richer on
average
many people in our culture choose the
latter approach both metaphorically and
also literally when it comes to money
and of course not all forms of Happiness
are equally as threatening to the
miserable selfish person
in fact he'll be very encouraging to you
if you are seeking pleasure in selfish
Pursuits
or if you're doing things that are
materialistic or shallow or you know
that aren't that meaningful
and and you're happy about it and you
talk about how you're happy about it
um these sorts of people they'll be very
encouraging of that they're happy okay
because that's that's uh that is a a
non-threatening sort of happiness
that you're experiencing
but this person sort of person is
especially offended by the happiness you
derive from
good true fulfilling things from a life
of service to your family that's the
that's the most offensive kind of
Happiness to them they hate that they
really hate it
that is the kind of happiness that this
sort of person hates most of all because
he has told himself
that that sort of happiness is
impossible
he's either childless and lonely facing
the prospect of dying alone and unloved
trying to convince himself that this is
the preferable option
or he has a family but his family is
broken and poisoned by resentment and
his kids hate him and his wife left him
or whatever or husband left him if it's
a man or woman uh and just everything's
in shambles
and they're trying to convince
themselves that it's not their fault
that this is always how it ends up with
families
All Families end up this way
well your happiness
in your family life interferes with this
mental narrative
and so they will hate you for it
like they're they're trying to lie to
themselves and you're getting in the way
of the LIE
and that's what lies at the root of all
of this
and it's why these pathetic miserable
wretches
not to add insult to injury you know not
that they need anymore
but they are all canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not I'll
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]